are you've gotten the chance to see
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice right
great that means we got some Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice spoiler
dog--and is a solid spoiler warning if
you want to see me talk about the movie
with no spoilers I have a spoiler free
review check that out but spoiler free
is not this video so you've been warned
so getting right into this can we just
talk about how rad Batman is is the
analytical detective Batman not really
is he kick-ass Batman yeah is he Batman
who doesn't kill people I don't think so
I'm pretty sure he slaughtered some
folks but they do a great setup for him
when he is in Metropolis and you see
Superman fighting Zod and I mean the
heat visions going everywhere buildings
are getting busted down he loses a
friend this movie really plays up the
fact that you shouldn't see eye to eye
with Batman I mean sometimes in this
movie Batman comes across as a dick but
he should be a dick it's just a
billionaire who dresses up like a bat
and fights crime he's not really sane
Alomar was talking about Batman
Rorschach in Watchmen is pretty much
Alan Moore's take on what Batman would
be like is like I wanted to explore what
a character like that would be like and
the answer is he to be a nutso when
Batman is completely blinded with this
phobia about this alien who could wipe
out the world it really has no ill
intent for mankind it's interesting for
me in fact any solid character in this
movie comes from Batman everything else
pretty thin that's part of my
frustration with Jesse Eisenberg's Lex
Luthor I've gotten a lot of tweets
people are like um you were wrong about
him he's Lex Luthor's son so he's
supposed to be that way
that's like saying Jar Jar Binks is a
Gungan so he's supposed to be that way
so we should all deal with the fact that
he's a [ __ ] character you know and what
I mean is Lex Luthor jr. could have been
better if they made him more like Lex
Luthor that we know because as he is
he's kind of a [ __ ] little weird
socially awkward twerp Bruce Wayne would
never work with someone like that and he
doesn't work with him in the movie but
would it have been better if Lex Luthor
was more of a business mind he was less
weird and socially awkward he was more
like Lex Luthor that you know he's more
like a Michael Rosenbaum Lex Luthor
named Bruce Wayne maybe could work with
him because Bruce Wayne's afraid of this
alien Lex Luthor's afraid of this alien
that should be a match made in heaven
those two should be working together
right now then maybe at the end when
Batman and Superman break bread and then
doomsday comes about he was like oh [ __ ]
my funding helps create that I really
have a vested interest in taking that
thing down because I'm
kind of a dick right now would have
added to Batman's character would have
added to Lex Luthor's character would
have made for a better scenario I
personally think but as it stands Lex
Luthor's just a weirdo I loved it when I
did a video on it I was like Jesse
Eisenberg is a horrible choice for Lex
Luthor people are like what about that
picture he looks awesome what is that
yeah at the very very end of the movie
he looks generally speaking like that
the biggest difference is in that
picture he doesn't have a big snot river
running out of his nose seriously at the
end when he's like monologuing in his
jail cell is like they're coming they're
coming yes I was like wipe your nose you
wipe your nose you wipe your [ __ ]
nose can you not right now can you just
wipe swipe your nose it's just really
gross I feel like I'm kind of jumping
track and jumping ahead to the end of
the movie where you find out that Lex
Luthor got a lot of knowledge through
that little crash Kryptonian ship and
he's coming pretty much tells me that
yeah Darkseid is in fact coming for the
Justice League movie and it's one of the
many Justice League tie-ins Wonder Woman
get to a little flash drive and you just
like blatantly see all the Justice
League times I actually thought they
were pretty cool out of place yeah it
looks like they could have filmed that
scene after the movie had completely
wrapped their lokay we have one more
thing we want a film I know we wrapped
like a year ago but let's just shoot
this into the movie someone told me
that's how it went down I feel like I
can see that but the point is the flash
cameo was cool the coolest one in that
video was cyborg I thought that was
really neat Aquaman was awkward he was
just like like they're like yeah memo
just look at the camera that's all you
got to do but also the flesh I believe
it was the flash I'm looking pretty sure
that it was the flash that came to Bruce
Wayne because it was a dude all in red I
don't really know Ezra Miller's face so
it might not be him I'm not really
familiar with the actor but I'm pretty
sure that when you have a dude dressed
all in red coming to someone in the DC
Universe in a vortex and a lightning
cloud I'm pretty sure it's probably the
flash is he obviously had knowledge he
was like loosely it's the key she's the
key to everything you were right about
him you were right about him like what
do you all right were you right about
Superman is Lois Lane really the key
really hope not because in this movie
her character was pretty [ __ ] Hollow
and she didn't do much at all but that
scene was pretty cool I got a set not
just Lois Lane but the whole Daily
Planet thing was pretty useless she's
trying to track down this bullet granted
where the bullet came from came from Lex
Corp and that was pretty important but
Lois Lane and her little crusade to find
out where the bullet came from and that
all the Daily Planet stuff Lex Luthor's
crusade even Batman and Bruce Wayne's
crusade and then the Wonder Woman thing
where she wants her hard drive back all
of it is in the movie but none of it
really ties together as well as it
probably should have for a movie that
setting up the DC Cinematic Universe I
don't know if that's the Zack Snyder
thing or a studio thing I really don't
know I do know at this point Zack Snyder
is pretty much flash over substance I
mean I there are scenes in this movie
roles oh that visually is great like
when Bruce Wayne's parents get killed
and then the pearls are around the gun
and it shoots and it cracks the Pearl
and they all go everywhere I was like
this looks great and that's what you get
when you're pitched as a visionary
director but any real moment in this
movie that tried to delve deeper into
the character just came across as flags
I just don't know that Zack Snyder knows
how to do that Zack Snyder strengths
come from when you have 300 Spartans
fighting a million Persians and they
just got to fight and defend their land
pretty simple but that's where home is
for him right stay in the pocket till
the end of this movie Batman finally
fights Superman which again I would have
preferred a world where Superman wanted
to fight Batman because Batman want to
fight Superman is like if you have
Batman fighting Superman because Batman
wants to fight Superman the Superman
fighting Batman because Superman wants
to fight Batman I find that bet I just
like that because their ideologies are
actually clashing with each other as it
stands Lex Luthor kidnapped Superman's
mom he's pretty much like you're gonna
beat the [ __ ] out of the bat that's
what's gonna happen so Superman's like I
guess I got to do that thing so it
wasn't really Batman vs Superman it was
Batman fighting Superman and Superman's
strong-armed into a fight he didn't
really want to be in however the fight
as it went down was pretty cool and
Batman had his gas grenades he's thrown
it at Superman he's like you're not
brave murder brave he has some good
lines that he throws at Superman but the
whole you're not brave men are brave did
anyone flashback to the Angus monologue
Georgie Scott does in the movie Angus
from back at 95 seriously YouTube Angus
Superman isn't brave and it's there
that's where I first saw it probably not
the first time it was ever said but it's
what this made me think of but
ultimately I do feel like that fight
ends too quickly because it's like smack
smack smack it looks nice it looks
pretty it looks cool
then all sudden Superman's all like
Martha we have to save Martha but
Martha's his mom's name Martha is also
Bruce Wayne's mom's name he was like
where'd you hear that name
we're drew gooden oh oh it's your mom
all right we're pals now then the
greatest kick-ass Batman scene in the
entire movie or a lot of Batman movies
happens when he wrecks that warehouse
full of dudes that you also saw in the
trailer then again with things that
don't really link to the movie in the
most cohesive way Lex Luthor has created
doomsday sand that doomsday is gonna
fight everybody and that's why doomsday
is in the last act of this movie he's in
the last act of this movie to fight and
then they fight and then that's that
which is also funny because when I was
bitching about how do first of all I
think doomsday does look like garbage
but that's not my problem with doomsday
my problem with doomsday is how he fit
or lack thereof into the movie tacky
looks like the cave troll from Lord of
the Rings it's just like another it's
like the fourth thing wrong with the
entire scenario which one I bitched
about at my trailer video that I did on
Batman vs Superman when they first
showed and people are like well he's
gonna evolve in the movie dude credit
where credit's do there is doomsday
evolution he does evolve into that
before that has no bone spurs whatsoever
he evolved a little more because Wonder
Woman cuts off his arm and then he has a
lot more bone spurs that come out of
there but generally speaking that's what
he looks like for most of the fight but
in this huge Throwdown happens and they
get nukes like Superman's like yep I'm
nuke proof I'm in space which is in the
comic book we've seen him being nuke
proof before so yeah it's lore nail work
together and they kill doomsday but not
before doomsday stabs the Superman in
his s and kills him too so they really
do the death of Superman in this movie
in some way shape or form which at first
I was like holy [ __ ] they really just
take that leap but I like because now
you'll have a Justice League that I
imagine Batman would get together but
it's not going to have Superman as the
flexors and he's not going to be the
captain of the ship now but I found that
pretty ballsy I was like that's pretty
cool then it shows the cast getting a
little pet
lift off the casket in the credits roll
and I was like oh never mind okay you're
just remaking on the whole thing I guess
it was funny because in this movie
Superman really didn't do much it's more
of a Batman movie than a Superman movie
so when Superman was dead
I found it ballsy but I found it okay I
was like well we didn't really we didn't
lose Batman that's the important thing
then now we all know he's alive and so
sorry all right well we don't really
it's not a big deal because any and the
biggest problems with this movie or the
fact that it's not cohesive it's pretty
all over the place it wants to be Batman
vs Superman but it really should have
been called dawn of Justice I guess if
you call it Donna Justice you don't have
the Batman and Superman brand in the
title it looks like there are attempts
at weaving the movie together but they
don't really flow like at the very
beginning that dude gets his legs
crushed and then Bruce Wayne saves him
and then that guy has a chip on his
shoulder for Superman and then Lex
Luthor uses him to do that Capitol
bombing explaining it here was a little
smoother than the movie's execution
because in the movie it's just they're a
bunch of disjointed story arcs that are
trying to weave together but they come
across as a bunch of disjointed story
arcs that man and everything he was in
the movie which is funny because he was
like the first fear I had for this
entire movie was Ben Affleck as Batman
turns out he's the best thing in the
movie I say the movies waste of
potential and some people get pissed at
me because I like what went into the
movie with the expectations you
shouldn't have yeah I went into Batman
versus [ __ ] Superman with
expectations that it would have been
more entertaining than it was weird I
know this is one thing I can call this
movie it is wasted potential
with moments of cool [ __ ] however I walk
away from this movie actually pretty
excited for the other Justice League
solo movies I want to see the flash now
I want to see Aquaman I want to see
Wonder Woman I want to see all of their
solo movies I want to see cyborg so
bring them all on let's check it out are
so Batman versus Superman have you
finally seen I imagine you've seen it
now like in my last reveals like have
you seen it what did you think about it
on Tuesday or Wednesday whenever I put
that up and now if you're gonna see it
this weekend you've seen it this weekend
so what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you
[Music]